the Joe Rogan experience especially a
few Trump oh well they're coming after
him right now right what are they coming
after him for now they'd like New York
State is allowing Congress to subpoenas
tax returns oh yeah yeah Deutsche Bank
they got his accountant is account
nothing to do with the federal
government I tell everybody why would
you want to be President like why would
you want to do that to yourself unless
you're super clean and let even if
you're super clean they're gonna make
[ __ ] up about you know the only reason
drunk did it is because you always Putin
so much money do you think so oh for
sure
pretty sure how did this lose their
billionaire get it get it financed over
and over and over again and guess who's
the laundering money like crazy from
Russia the guy that needs the money no
the whole Trump family's going to go
down you think so oh-ho-ho for sure
taxes man Al Capone the Donald Trump you
can't evade taxes so do you think that
he owes taxes the he owes Putin he
always Putin so much money that he's
scared to death how do you know this
common sense okay so it's a guess oh no
they figured out okay let's go down the
history call me is a FBI right more FBI
trump was attacking Obama was the
birther Obama's a president obama's got
control of the FBI CIA everybody so
obama says okay find out about this
trunka so they found out about him but
the thing is they can't really do
anything unless he becomes president
other than that he just walked away free
do anything unless he becomes president
yeah or you mean there's no break in the
law that there's no law that says that
you can't deal with russia right only
law says you can't deal with russia and
be the president of the united states
right time
right the only time he would break any
laws is that if if he became president
right and he has to become president and
he became president it thanks to call me
because Hillary was going to win no
matter what they say Hillary was gonna
win until Comey said oh and they knew
they knew back in Obama time that there
was nothing really wrong that Hillary
did nothing nothing but they told her to
release emails she deleted 30,000 of
them so but she wasn't supposed to do
that
that's illegal and she was using her own
personal email server instead of the
government's which were it was I don't
lay dienes inconvenience more than more
than anything illegal you know she
wasn't looking to get finance to her
hotel by the Russians you know she
wasn't looking for money hmm
her and Bill had money they got money
yeah yeah I think it's a little fishy a
little [ __ ] little stinky stuff around
there well but it's normal it's it's uh
normal politics oh so my theory is is
that Comey and the FBI said let's get
this guy so you think they let him
become president so they get him I think
bars part of the part of the the the the
Comey gang this you know what's gonna be
hilarious about this this video when
people watch this thing I go how high is
Tommy Chong
Tommy Charles made Trump presidents so
they could prosecute them yeah yeah
that's an interesting theory yeah but
think about how think anybody's
controlling the strings that well but
puppeteers are that good listen if look
at everybody that was around Trump that
became chief of staff and everything
else right all military right why
because chunk Trump's got his finger on
the button
he's got a bill ADEA to get on the
button and so in order to keep him in
line they got people around him that can
keep him in right yeah yeah FBI they can
infiltrate anything they infiltrated the
mob for years they infiltrated the Hells
Angels do you think they couldn't
infiltrate
Trump's gang but do you think they were
trying to absolutely will be just
because him going after Obama with the
birther stuff it's a start
yeah you mess with the president look at
that and other people weren't saying he
was from Kenya right there's some
ridiculous
Photoshop analysis and he's a birth
certificate anything anything to keep a
black guy from being a president yeah
and that's what they found out easy and
and and and the FBI and the federal
lives you know against racism and that's
pretty pretty pretty strict it's pretty
heavy
you know until Trump cotton and so so so
anyway this my theory that debt that's
something he's got a theory right there
yeah like like I I really feel that
Giuliani
as part of the the scheme to keep Trump
you know why was hope well he could some
hope you know hey they can't look at
your taxes you're the president for
chrissake you know you're the supreme
leader you know well he does have
there's some things they won't do when
you're in office absolutely won't indict
you for certain things and so they plan
it well look at mother said he says I'm
gonna hand this off to the Congress
mm-hmm you can impeach him here's all
the evidence you need to impeach him and
no the Democrats that gotta figure out
are we going to impeach him go through
that or are we just going to go to the
election and beat assassin election and
then then arrest him after the election
who do you think is gonna beat him in
the election anybody anybody you think
Joe Carter them oh yeah really oh yeah
you are high huh no strong weaned what
are you getting it well look at look at
the Trump the trunk backers for instance
right can you find one thinker in that
backing group well I mean who are we
were talking about the same thing you
know the can can can think a racism
blind you right but what racism racism
is ignorance it's its appearance I've
got a demon I had it in my family you
know so I know exactly I've been I've
been you know kissing close to racist
and I know that mentality and so you
yeah ignorance doesn't stop with one
thing it carries on to a lot of a lot of
other things like work and like all
sorts of things
and so when you look at the people that
are opposing Trump you know the the
women
the the kids the intellectuals the the
liberals progressives all those people
they want a good future for our country
you know the other ones they just want
to keep everybody else out or perceived
enemies its perceived enemies that
anyone late anybody with a gun that's
the whole thing you know
[Applause]